the 2018 Winter Olympics in South Korea
are just about a month away and if any
transgender athletes seek to compete
they'll be welcomed with open arms
IOC rules allow for transgender athletes
to compete as their preferred gender a
biological male winning a gold medal in
a women's event now seems a matter of
when not if joanna Harper is
transgendered and an athlete and argues
that transgender competitors don't enjoy
any advantage
Jona there are a lot of people who in
this age of gender fluidity take a
relaxed view of it and accept that you
can choose which bathroom to use and and
all that but that when it comes to sport
when it comes to who's the fastest who's
the strongest when you're running around
a 400 meter track that basically from
gender fluidity we're back to two
biological sexes in which those who are
born male have a distinct advantage
where they going wrong on that well
first of all biology is actually quite
complex and so to suggest that the that
biology is dimorphic is incorrect but
but it is certainly true that people who
have gone through male puberty
especially do have substantial
advantages and to be clear the IOC rules
say that transgender women can only
compete in women's sports after they
have gone through a year of low
testosterone due to hormone therapy and
that actually changes many biological
characteristics and especially those
characteristics that are important for
sport but um and the second the second
thing I'd like to say is that I've
always admitted that transgender women
have advantages over cisgender or
typical women but also disadvantages too
and the important question is can the
two groups compete against one another
equitably and meaningfully well let's
let's look at the at the the tests and
the testing that you mentioned where
they say you have to and maybe you can
actually explain this in in layman's
terms you're a scientist you understand
a lot of this but lowering testosterone
and I think the the the thing is you
have to have your testosterone levels
below 10 nanometer and if I think about
it carefully enough I could remember
what a nano mole was if for my school
days if one drops from the ceiling on my
head but 10 nanomoles per liter as I
understand it something like 90% of
female athletes their testosterone
levels around 3 nanomoles per liter so
you know in other words this upper limit
is 3 times what would be typical in a
female athlete so it seems like a kind
of arbitrary setting unrelated to the
realities of the situation well I
actually agree with you there and in
fact I am part of a committee that has
recently recommended that we lower that
limit from 10 to 5 and it's important to
understand that that's a limit the vast
majority of transgender women will keep
their testosterone below 3 and in fact
below 2 and usually below 1 nano more so
so this is an upper limit but I
absolutely agree 10 is too high and our
committee has recommended bringing it
down to 5 you you mentioned that it's
not like a binary boy-girl thing there
was a I think she was a South African a
fleet who competed in the Olympics and
the Commonwealth Games a couple of years
back and fellow female competitors were
convinced that at a certain level she
was transgendered and in fact I think
the authorities ended up actually
testing her to find out whether she was
transgendered because her levels were
believed to be extraordinarily high I
wonder if we're in danger in the end of
just killing
women's sport by this kind of micro
regulation of the essentially the
individual DNA of each participant well
first of all the athlete in question
caster Semenya was almost undoubtedly
intersex which some people may not be
familiar with that term butBut
hermaphrodite is a term that more people
might be familiar with but but intersex
people have a mix of male and female
characteristics and Semenya is almost
undoubtedly intersex so so there are
different issues than with transgender
athletes and it's important to separate
the two but again it is important to
have fair play it is important to that
that introducing intersex and/or
transgender athletes does not overly
affect the the playing field that exists
and transgender athletes in particular
are hugely under represented in women's
sports well we'll see in other words if
you were to look at the population of
transgender athletes you would expect
that there would be a lot more athletes
than there actually are well we will see
where where that ends up Joanna may well
be that men and women just end up
running around the track altogether and
there aren't these separate events
anymore